- All right.
Settle, please.
This is it, Bobby.
All right.
Here we go.
Roll camera.
- What am I doing?
- I'll do my thing,
and I'll go whoa.
You just react.
- OK.
- [shouts]
- Oh, whoa.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
- God.
What the--
- You need your phone.
- OK.
- Phone's supposed
to be in your hand.
Scare you?
- Yeah.
Sorry about that.
Let's do it.
Here we go.
- OK.
- I'm going to vomit.
Power things up.
- Let's line it up.
- Speeding.
Rolling.
Here we go.
This is for real.
Bobby will do the jump.
And action.
- [shouts]
- Whoa!
- Cut.
- Wow.
- [clapping]
- Whew.
- Nice job.
- Yeah, Bobby.
- One take wonder, over here.
- Yeah.
- I'm glad they liked it.
But that hurt.
In training, I learned to keep
my chin down and body flat.
But I didn't do that on
set, and I paid the price.
- And now, I know.
It ain't easy.
But the successful
stunts are the ones
you can walk away from.
- Appreciate that.
Appreciate that.
- Bobby, you good?
- Yeah.
The fall was the thing
I was most afraid of.
- All right.
Now, down to your final
F. And that is fire.
- All right, Bobby.
In position.
- But the burn is the thing that
I think is the most dangerous.
- I have a Molotov cocktail
that I will drop into position.
And that will ignite your arm.
Are you ready?
- Is anyone really ready
to ever be set on fire?
- [laughs]
- All right.
We all set?
Johnny, you ready?
- Yes, sir.
- OK.
Light the Molotov.
- You need this
right here, right?
- Here we go.
- Everything in my mind
is saying, this is insane.
[bottle shatters]
- [yells]
- Calm down.
There you go.
Give me his face.
- Wave it.
Wave it.
Good.
Go back to the fire.
- [yells]
- Are you OK?
- Yeah.
The hardest part about
that is letting it burn
and not reacting to it.
- You did a good job.
- Thank you.
I feel good.
- All right, Bobby.
Just one more.
I'm kidding.
That was great.
We got it.
We totally got it.
- Oh, my goodness.
- [laughs] Nice job, man.
You really did good job.
- Thank you.
I was pretty proud of myself.
I felt like I handled
that pretty well.
[music]